yeah welcome to this video and in the 15
minute game on icc I start with Knight
f3 stay flexible and let's see what
setup bomb Black is going for here so
King sinyun noise chatting here saying
hello um yeah okay let's play see form
go for some English type of position of
course black hat some many viable setups
now yeah this for instance going to
gruene felt like positions so let's just
castle and see what happens now I can
play deform I can take on d5 and so the
main moves Kenneth let's capture yeah
okay now can play deform directly
transposing to the gruene thought of
line Knight c3 stay within English
territory but black hand player 96cm I
possibly we get a good father after all
you can also go see 5 can take 96 yeah
typical for the English opening there
are many options it's not a very fast
opening with many concrete lines it's
more yeah it's very flexible so you've
got very often the white area of choice
yeah he captured on c3 now the question
should black play see 5 or play without
c5 yeah he decided to go without this
upon move
yeah die-off also more than one possible
set up I can play with the deform taking
the center or can play a slightly more
restrained set up with d3 not
immediately of course because c3 saying
but I can prepare these three four one
two ok when without go to deform then
probably yeah maybe we'll play if I've
even i'm not sure that i like that so
much it's a bad but can also play a book
like rugby one provoking something on
the queenside because I tag b7 yeah
maybe let's play this one trying to
tickle I'm a bit and see how he handles
the beep on maybe he just done to play
rugby aid I want nothing of the sort and
just please if five so what about d3 now
is it a good move tee three yeah he
might play you form this is a to be
considered yeah but this shouldn't be
too too dramatic before I can also just
take he can take c3 but I have lots of
open lines of the coincide then aha now
he moves the rock so how to proceed
further where does the bishop go a 3 III
g5 yeah lots of possibilities g5 might
provoke some weakening move like f6 on a
similar can also move the night of
course night d2c 492 Gabi three looks a
bit silly but c4 maybe so possibility I
could also try to play efore in deform
yeah so more than one plan as mentioned
yeah I like to reposition the night
this also opens up the bishop he cannot
go let's say be six now it's a very nice
strong diagonal g2 yeah of course are
simply threatened to take out so I
cannot lets him play rookie a deck just
takes his sixth and win apiece so he
needs to learn the app probably moved
the bishop which she probably wants to
do anyway there should be six for
example looks like I'm a good move that
could also play Queen a form Queenie for
looks som like an active possibility
yeah also cover some day the h upon
ganton
good idea here is night efore to see 5
which looks really nice I would get
there this enum it would it would help
me a great deal yes Bishop to g5 yeah I
thought I thought reform that maybe I
should just play 19 forward he has a god
f5 this is some ok this is no problem
really at five I have Bishop g5 then and
his only got them got quite sodium
places for his queen Knight 94 f5 Bishop
g5 if he goes Quinn to see a d8 whatever
I've got 90 f6 check and then take on d5
was check he needs to keep cover here
needs to cover d5 because of this Knight
f6 discovery yeah and on Queen d7 I have
95 here should be fine so f5 Bishop g5
Queen to d7 95 should be really good and
queen e 8 9 sx he can go 927 but after
this move from the RAF various
interesting ideas Queen
three for example and this even a crazy
line f5 Bishop g5 97 rock d1f take c4d
takes d4 and I win the peace bag with
the rook on the default yeah I'm not
sure this is a great idea but it's so
funny technical point yeah he went 5-5
hmm yeah if I'm not playing them Bishop
g5 it's all very silly right so let's go
55 our 97 I simply can take also of
course 97 Bishop e7 Queenie 796 check
takes whatever with whatever peace
bishop d5 and then we'll p7 I win a porn
at the end at least the porn and it's
probably am also great position so am I
don't really see a bull and a good news
yeah Knight f6 is really a problem let's
say Queenie a TR Knight f6 check you
should have six Bishop takes d5 check
King moves from f6f 6 ruko 6 yeah okay
this is basically the same okay but are
not the not so quickly not so good let's
spend a second here maybe I've got even
a better move I've also I've got night
to d6 to consider
mmm 96 c takes bishop t5 king edge aid
but I don't have a really great
continuation then I think I probably can
win a pawn in various ways yes still
night f6 look so makes a strong
impression ray yeah okay we'll take with
the bishop done so i'll take here and
one now for take on f6c can recapture
with the rook and it's not clear how i
immediately i mean i can i can win the
pond or something bishop c6 but i don't
want that of course my bishop is also
stronger than its night it sir and it
won't touch if I if I just capture but I
don't know Bishop f6 rock f6 also helps
them in some way to to get the the rook
active I shouldn't I think I should just
retreat him and maybe retain the
possibility of Bishop c5 and ya Tek a 7
also yeah the bishop only three is
stronger than the bush won a six-hour
should should really capture yeah now
it's not so easy
even covering c6 is a problem quindi 7am
can complain then I will really simply
can can take on c6 I grab material if
you will play move like f4 of course I
wouldn't wouldn't take it just play
Bishop c5 keep all the positional alarm
advantages yeah and he also needs to be
aware of possibilities of rook takes b7
and in some positions let's say we play
rook e8 now then Bishop then rook takes
b7 is also a possibility rugby seven and
then piece takes Bishop c6 and I winner
exchange back with the Ute advantage but
of course on rook e8 I could also simply
takes you six and it's a pawn and a good
position yeah I think I think whatever
he needs to play isn't like we need
sound now but i can just takes you six
they will want to be texts six queen a7
it serve is simply it's simply good for
wired probably don't see any special
kind of compensation
well that's good to give 97 maybe 97
yeah when I can I can just drop it back
to g2 a7s also hanging so 97 Bishop g2
what what to do about a 7 some difficult
yeah black is in a difficult position
he's some taking us Tommy I hope you
didn't disconnect yeah this would be
rather rather said after doing 15
minutes of comentary yeah but it's um
it's a very unpleasant position I
understand that he wants to invest a bit
of time to find some move I really don't
see one I really setting stairs firing
move maybe that's none that's also not
good I just thought briefly a night eh
maybe with the idea to play c6 blunting
the d5 Bishop around night da de can
just play Bishop c5 and embarrass this
rook okay you went queen dee sem now
this is the most natural move probably
now rook takes be 70 can just take d 5
would be on a moment I can then see 7s
saying what study has got 97
okay but the simple solution would be
just a text for six if i take c 6 Bishop
Bishop c6 Quincy 626 bc6 Bishop e7 it's
just a pawn for nothing on rook a 8 i've
got rupees heaven so I'm basically
winning okay if I take the 60 cakes bc6
queen 87 ruka ATM and I've got Quincy
five and he cannot play Brooke a two
because of Bishop h61 in the exchange
dad should be very good for me still it
always hurts a bit too to give gift this
bishop should I really do it yeah I
guess it's time to cash in already here
win material yeah I smoked weed c6 I
think it's losing straightaway just
giving away a subnetwork besom let's
this is just a winning end game with the
a porn oh he allows this hope I'm not
overlooking anything the point is really
rook a 8am is answered by rugby 7 and I
control the beef island have this super
strong look on the seventh of course if
I would unroll gate if I would need to
move the bishop somewhere
yeah I will need to move the bishop then
he would have some counter play on the a
porn but he I can just go look be 7 next
move also on any other rookie move
rookie aid or something I just play
rugby 7 and have fun really big
advantage okay look to be semyonov
attacking also see seven and he's not
able to do much how am I should improve
them look to be one simply yeah maybe
ought to be one I could have can also
look a one or a form that this move was
a bit superficial yeah maybe I should
have played okay one on afore i always
have deform so this isn't a problem okay
but rook rook to be one didn't spoil
anything he cannot do much anyway I can
still play alright i'm not sure what
this move is doing some weird technical
idea maybe maybe once play i will get
bishop d2 maybe rip to dt 2 hmm I don't
know shouldn't be really dangerous okay
let's move the a pond
this is the winning pawn anyway the long
run yeah Andrew could be three edges
thought so somewhat weird the special
bondi to right in the middle of my
position but the winning idea now would
be a 5 a 6 rook a 3 move the bishop and
then win yeah okay maybe got some little
tricks yeah okay cannot play f3 because
of rook takes a 7 and this is a new
trick can I can just go here right f2 is
protected he will never get any any play
on the f porn and next move I can simply
play f3
yeah rookie is just answered by on
Jessie five maybe even also have three
it's still possible just making this all
super secure on the King side yeah white
spawn structures very M come back here
don't have any weakness okay try and
maybe g5 h4m some counter play okay now
I'll push the ape on it is rather quick
young really take some time until it's
got any kind of a tech on the King side
yeah so now let's go f3 super solid hmm
rook takes a seven maybe well this was
really a threat but it doesn't hurt to
have this all secured alright so yeah I
need to kill a DA porn is so now I'm
ready to play a 6 a-6 move the bishop
yep okay I need to cross retreat now
I could have gone through the
fourth-ranked also maybe this would have
been better covering E for g 4 and so on
ok but it shouldn't be a real difference
a six move the bishop a seven and it's
silver at least that's what I hope yeah
maybe it's got some veggies like a forum
you phone yeah still it doesn't really
matter yeah I can take with both both
pawns both both should win I can also
play Bishop g4 yeah but no real reason
let's take with this it's not much of a
difference ready okay I now Bishop here
play a seven I will be eight
yeah but this is just one check right
Luke h2 King g1 and that's it right I
could also have been I could also
promote immediately but this is a new
queen complete Queen so yeah I know him
and that's it oops okay get this really
threatening check made um okay let's
just go back here may I should have just
proven promote it would have been a bit
bit simpler I hope there's really no
threats IAM nano cover the first rank
and it's got no checks or anything
always feels bad if you if you think
okay now resins that he actually has a
list of threatened made in one
yeah it's down to 30 seconds I'd really
no move guys letting the clock run down
okay with probably searching for some
miracle move but there there is none I
just get them get the new queen okay
that's really no trick right okay let's
get the Queen yeah this is it
threatening mate yeah almost almost okay
jack takes you six I guess damn it
should be three probably a nice running
all the way Cal went on time but I don't
want to burn on time after I make some
stupid move black four votes on time
okay yeah um gets too quick recap of
this game I think the issue here was
this f5 move I mean this kind of
position looks slightly better for white
I've got these ideas on the coincident
he doesn't have any specific counterplay
black is still solid of course but this
is this is a mistake really Bishop g5
now leads to some advantage for white as
always this checks on f6 so you went
here
but let's say would go here cut got this
move which is even even worse move the
Queen again I can also just take this
and turn this doesn't really help 97
I've got to at least this this kind of
stuff and oops it's a pawn and a good
position I'll probably win another
component of the coincide and I just
simply have too much better bishop yeah
this f5 allowed this Bishop g5 with him
he needs to play some some solid
consolidating muth not quite sure what
move if you would that save play h 6 ER
just for example to get get this Bishop
g5 out of the position I've got this
idea and what should you do I think you
need to retreat yet this is just a nice
a nice position with two bishops let's
go here but this I know let's say here
I've goregaon light c5 also coming again
white is just better I've got this play
on the queenside and he doesn't have
much to show for it yeah but the f5
really leads to its huge problems yeah
96 is so the computer computers move
here yeah solve this line also the ideas
of him what I just thought what I played
with lots of fine this IDM the computer
wants to play like this and now now we
should be 7f yeah this is of course also
good
winning the pawn shop but this is also
huge pressure our material on the
coincide it's possible to to hold this
yeah thanks for watching